- Forget Wonder Woman's
golden lassos and tiaras.
The Amazons of ancient myth
were much more gruesome
than any DC comic heroine.
According to the legends,
they were man-hating,
baby-killing war machines
who cut off their own breasts
just so they could shoot
their arrows better.
Amazons were the
fearsome, worthy opponents
that male heroes had to defeat
to prove their battle prowess.
- But were these warrior women even real?
Images of fiercely independent Amazons
could be found on countless
vases, sculptures,
and buildings from antiquity.
Yet over time, they faded into myth
along with the dryads and centaurs.
Scholars have debated their
existence for decades,
but recent archeological discoveries
might have finally solved this mystery.
(lilting music)
- [Moiya] TV shows like
"Xena: Warrior Princess"
and comics like "Wonder Woman"
paint a seemingly contradictory
picture of Amazons
as terrifying but attractive,
isolated from the world but
still compassionate enough
to aid those they deem worthy.
Modern media also gives
the distinct impression
that Amazons were merely
figures of fantastical myth.
These depictions surely
wouldn't have sat well
with ancient Greek writers
who saw Amazons as very real,
but savagely brutish people.
The oldest surviving written
mention of the Amazons
can be found in Homer's "The
Iliad," penned around 700 BCE,
a time when the boundary
between myth and history
was so fuzzy it was almost non-existent.
"The Iliad" tells the
story of the Trojan War,
which supposedly happened five centuries
before Homer's time,
though modern archeologists
are skeptical that a
war of quite that scale
actually happened the way Homer described.
Still, the Amazons' presence in the story
suggests that they were in
the Greek cultural zeitgeist
as far back as the Bronze Age.
Recent findings from grave sites
in parts of Russia and
Ukraine have scholars thinking
that his descriptions of the warrior women
may have also been exaggerated.
But first, let's take a closer look
at how Amazons have been
depicted in literature and art.
- [Emily] The great Heracles
was rumored to have fought
the Amazons and emerged victorious
during the ninth of his 12 famous labors.
The Amazon Queen Hippolyta
wore a leather girdle, or belt,
that was supposedly gifted
to her by her father Ares
for being her people's fiercest fighter.
King Eurystheus, who
assigned Heracles his labors,
had a daughter who
coveted Hippolyta's belt,
so Heracles was sent to retrieve it.
He sailed with a small
armada across the Black Sea
to the Amazons' distant
and mysterious homeland.
When he arrived, Hippolyta agreed
to give him the girdle without bloodshed,
but the goddess Hera had other ideas.
She convinced the Amazons that
their queen was in danger,
so they attacked Heracles' forces.
Hippolyta was struck down
in the ensuing battle,
and Heracles took her belt back to Tiryns
and its greedy king.
Despite his many impressive opponents,
the moment where Heracles
defeats Hippolyta
is one of his most oft-depicted
laborers in classical art.
What a convenient way for
artists to uphold male heroism
while simultaneously reminding
women what can happen
if they stray from their designated roles.
In other later versions of the story,
either Hippolyta or another
powerful Amazon named Antiope
was stolen away to Athens
to be King Theseus' bride.
The Amazons besieged
Athens to bring her home,
but were ultimately defeated
by this mighty city state.
This battle known as the Amazonomachy
is featured on the west
side of the Parthenon.
- In Homer's epic poem and other
accounts of the Trojan War,
the Amazons were led into battle
by their Queen Penthesilea
to fight for Troy after their hero Hector
was slain by Achilles.
Penthesilea's motivation
for joining the war effort
is unclear, perhaps
she was repaying a debt
to her old foe Priam,
the last king of Troy,
or maybe she and her army
were paid mercenaries
hired by a desperate monarch.
Some say she was seeking
retribution through glory
for murdering one of her fellow Amazons.
Whatever her reasoning,
the story of Amazons in the Trojan War
ends much like every other Greek tale
featuring these fearsome warriors.
They fought with enough bravery and skill
to diminish the Greek ranks,
but not enough to turn the tide of war.
Queen Penthesilea herself
was eventually slain
by the Greek hero Achilles,
who according to some writers
like Arctinus of Miletus,
fell in love with her beauty
after her helmet was removed in death.
You're a worthy opponent,
but no match for the great Achilles.
- I think I can handle a little boy
talks about himself in the third person.
- Who are you? You're weak.
You're despicable, you're disgusting.
(gasps) You're beautiful!
Oh, no, what have I done?
I love you, my Amazon queen!
But wait, don't I also love Patroclus?
Why can't these writers
just make up their minds?
In this story, the Amazon serve
as little more than
convenient plot devices
designed to bolster the
reputation of Greece's military
and give their greatest hero
a sharp but romantic edge.
Thanks to misogyny and the
fact that no writing survived
from anyone who clearly
fit the Amazon description,
these stories were
dismissed as obvious fiction
over the next two millennia.
The fearsome Amazons were written off
as pro-Athens propaganda,
or reimagined as beardless male foreigners
who the Greeks mistook
for battleworn women.
That is until a Swiss law
professor named Johann Bachofen
published a paper in 1861
making the radically feminist claim
that Amazons were more than just myth,
and that early humans
were naturally matriarchal
before the disease of patriarchy set in.
- But there was no proof
of the Amazons' legitimacy
until the 1970s when
genetic testing technology
made it possible for archeologists
to accurately determine
the sex of ancient remains.
Because despite what some
corners of the internet claim,
you cannot tell the sex
of a long-deceased person
just by looking at the
shape of their skeleton.
In the 1940s, archeologists uncovered
hundreds of burial mounds called kurgans
in the Great Steppes of eastern
Europe and central Asia,
a region of dry open grasslands
to the northeast of Greece.
The kurgans were left
around the fifth century BCE
by the myriad nomadic tribes
famous for their horse handling
known to the Greeks as Scythians,
Thracians or Sauromatians.
Hey boss, I found a grave site.
- What's in it?
- A bow, some daggers, a cool headpiece.
- It's a male warrior!
- Do you wanna look at
the actual remains first?
- Oh no, that'd be silly.
What can those bones tell me
that the weapons and my rigid
notion of gender roles cannot?
- Originally, the archeologists
assumed the bodies buried
with weapons were all male
because well, of course they did.
2,500 years after Homer and our scientists
still couldn't imagine
a society that allowed,
let alone encouraged their women to fight.
But the genetic testing revealed
that one third of the kurgans
were eternal resting places
for female warriors,
buried with weapons, armor,
and evidence of battle
wounds just like the men.
Suddenly the puzzle pieces
started falling into place.
Most myths have a kernel of truth in them
if you know how to look for it,
and this archeological evidence
was the magnifying glass
scholars had been waiting for.
Adrienne Mayor, a folklorist and historian
who literally wrote the book
on separating Amazon fact from fiction,
believes Scythian women were
the real world inspiration
for ancient Greece's mythical opponents.
Early artistic depictions of the Amazons
even showed them wearing Scythian fashion.
- There has never been evidence
of an all-female society of
warriors across the Black Sea
who modify their chests and
murder their male children,
but we do know that the
Scythians were active
and roaming near the Black Sea by 900 BCE.
By the time Homer wrote "The Iliad,"
Greeks interacted with
Scythians regularly,
and it's not hard to imagine
how they could have invented
such monstrous figures
by embellishing some of
their northeastern neighbors'
more unfamiliar traits.
Homer was an author trying
to write a memorable story,
after all.
The reality of Greek
mythology's favorite war girlies
is much more mundane.
The Great Steppes are a harsh environment
with few resources,
so the Scythians had to
travel and fight to survive.
This bred a culture
where girls learned to
ride their prized horses
and shoot their innovative
bows just like the boys did.
Still, many of the men
were likely to have died
during hunts or raids,
giving the impression
that there weren't many of them around.
- The myth about Amazons killing
or abandoning their male
children could have arisen
from the common nomadic
practice of fosterage
where a family leaves their
son with a neighboring tribe
for safety, education, or
to strengthen an alliance.
It was also a convenient way
for the Greeks to
support their false claim
that Amazons shunned all men.
Oh, and that myth about their chests?
That one is just flimflam
from the fifth century BCE.
So-called historian Hellanicos
was trying to derive the
meaning of the word Amazon
by using Greek roots, even
though it wasn't a Greek word.
He claimed it meant "without breast,"
but Amazons were almost never shown
with this particular adaptation in art,
and even his contemporaries
dismissed his idea as absurd.
The true origin of the word
Amazon remains a mystery.
- So it seems that the brutal
misandrist Amazons of lore
didn't really exist,
but they were caricatures
of a real culture
remarkably different from ancient Greece,
one where women weren't relegated
to prim and proper domestic roles.
Consider me disappointed, then,
that Greek writers didn't
include some of the coolest
and most deviant aspects
of Scythian culture
into their monstrous myths,
like the abundant tattoos
or the fact that most of them
carried hemp-burning kits
in their travel packs.
Most of the world was fooled
by the Amazons' descent into myth,
but there's a tiny island
off the coast of Turkey
that still honors the
memory of the real Amazons,
women of the Eurasian nomadic tribes
who fought with just as much
bravery and skill as the men.
This Aksu festival on Giresun Island
is celebrated every May
and heavily features
the sacred Hamza stone,
which locals believe was
worshiped by the Amazons
who lived there millennia ago.
- [Emily] We can learn so
much from Giresun Island
about the power of local memory.
Imagine how different the
last 2000 years might've been
if we had all remembered
that women can fight ferociously enough
to give demigod heroes
a run for their money
in even the most biased stories.
Unlike Homer, we can't change history
through our embellishments,
but moving forward,
we can all embody more
of what Adrienne Mayor
calls the "Amazon spirit."
Essentially, this is the belief
that women are equal to
men in courage and skill.
You know, the very message that characters
like Wonder Woman and Xena
were created to convey.
- [Moiya] Now it's time
for the next pantheon pick,
and I'm excited to
bring some Amazon spirit
to our utopia with Hippolyta.
- Yes!
I feel like our utopia
needs some leadership energy
and it doesn't have to be a monarchy.
We can choose whatever
type of government we want,
but we need someone
who can lead the people
and if that person can also defend
against any incoming
raids, then that's great.
- Added bonus.
I think that's a great
pick and I like the idea
of taking almost like a demigod
or someone more human and adding them
'cause what's utopia without diversity?
- [Moiya] Exactly. I love it.
So that's our pantheon
pick for this episode
but be sure to tune in
for the rest of the season
because we will be picking a new deity
at the end of every episode.
And next time it's Dr. Z's turn to pick.
- I can't wait to see what you think!
With Dr. McKees- McKees?
(Moiya laughs)
I gotta go.
- Dr. Mc-
- Oh my God, you almost did it too! McKee.
- Dr. McKee.
- Dr. McKee!